these days peaceful protest in our
nation's capital against our corrupt
ruling class is liable to get a man
arrested
so I figured if I'm going to get
arrested for what I say on this campus
tour I might as well get it over with at
the first stop so that I can save myself
the trouble of writing all of those
additional speeches
I don't think that I will be arrested
for my speech here tonight
but it is a distinct possibility
happening a lot recently and I'm not
even talking about the January 6th
people I'm sorry excuse me
the January 6th the very worst day in
the history of this or any Republic
the day are sacred democracy nearly
collapsed
I'm not I'm not talking about that but I
do want to be precise lest I share the
fate of that amiable horn hat guy and
all of the midwestern grannies who are
rotting away in solitary for the high
crime of taking a selfie in the capital
rotunda I don't want to end up there
when I talk about the possibility of
being arrested in Washington D.C for
peaceful protest I'm not referring to
the January 6th people it is true many
of those people did nothing violent and
were even escorted into the capital by
Capitol Hill Police it is true that even
the very worst acts that took place on
January 6th paled in comparison to the
half dozen other mostly leftist attacks
that have taken place at the Capitol
that our establishment media have memory
hold I'm thinking of course of attacks
such as the 1915 bombing of the Senate
reception room by a Harvard professor of
course it was a Harvard professor
I'm thinking of the shooting by Puerto
Rican radicals that left five
congressmen injured in 1954 radicals who
were later granted clemency by Jimmy
Carter of course
I'm thinking of attacks such as the 1971
bombing of the capital by the far left
Weather Underground whose co-founder
Bill Ayers was a mentor to Barack Obama
or the 1983 bombing of the capital by
the radical armed resistance unit in
protest of President Reagan's policy in
Grenada and Lebanon and some other
attacks too
all of those were obviously orders of
magnitude more serious and criminal than
anything carried out by the January 6th
demonstrators who were apparently so
inept at Insurrection that not one of
them remembered to bring any weapons
which is good
when I talk about the possibility of
being arrested in Washington D.C for
peaceful protest I'm not talking about
the January 6th there's some of whom at
least were unruly I am talking about the
eight pro-life Advocates who are
currently in jail and facing 11 years
behind bars for peacefully protesting at
an infanticide Mill The Operators of
which were proven to have regularly
violated federal law conducted illegal
abortions deprived babies born alive of
federally mandated medical care and
hidden their Crimes by improperly
disposing of the baby's bodies the
abortionist in charge admitted to these
sorts of crimes on camera
eight pro-life Advocates peacefully
demonstrated against the clinic Lauren
handy John Hinshaw Heather ridoni
William Goodman herb Garrity Joan Bell
Jonathan Darnell and Gene Marshall
these pro-life Advocates unlike the
infanticidal butcher that they were
protesting cesare santangelo have never
killed anyone
they would never heard a fly and yet
they are currently sitting in jail
some of them are quite young herb
Garrity is 25 years old
some of them are a bit older
Joan Bell is 74. she is the mother of
seven she and her husband Chris have
raised one biological child and six
adopted children all adopted with
disabilities and one saved from abortion
by the bell's heroic decision to adopt
that child
Joan is the kind of menace to society
that our rulers are presently locking up
for more than a decade which at the age
of 74 could well mean death in a prison
cell
our President Joe Biden is right down
the street
he could easily pardon Joan and the rest
of the pro-life Advocates this very
minute
Joe Biden is Catholic
at least nominally
Joe Biden in particular has a moral
responsibility to free Joan and the rest
of the pro-life political prisoners at
the very least he could commute their
sentences
but he won't do that
of course he won't it was his Jack
booted Thugs who arrested them in the
first place
there were crimes taking place at cesare
santangelo's abortion clinic
there still are
but when the police showed up they
didn't arrest the criminals
they arrested the pro-life Advocates
peaceably bringing attention to the
criminals crimes
and this wasn't just some mix-up
some miscommunication between the chief
executive and his Law Enforcement
Officers if it were Biden would have
intervened
but he won't because Prison is precisely
where he wants these pro-lifers
it's evil
imprisoning people for peaceably
demonstrating in defense of the most
vulnerable Among Us little babies
butchered by a psychopath who in
addition to the bare fact of his
infanticide also flagrantly violates
federal law
what Biden has done is as evil a
political act as one can imagine
which got me thinking
and which also got me into trouble on
Twitter
I've noticed that thinking frequently
gets people into trouble in politics
we hear a lot about our evil foreign
adversaries Vladimir Putin in Russia Xi
Jinping in China
both rulers who have done many evil
Things No Doubt
and yet
presented with the case of these eight
pro-life prisoners a distressing thought
entered my mind
is it possible that our own President
Joe Biden is as evil a ruler as Putin or
she
is it possible that our President Joe
Biden
is even more evil a ruler than Putin or
she it seems crazy I know and yet
I just can't get the nagging thought out
of my mind
chairman she operates in tournament
camps for uyghurs a Muslim minority in
Northwest China
she uses these uyghurs for forced labor
a crime condemned around the world but
with condemnations that lose some of
their credibility when we discover that
the products that the uyghurs have been
forced to build are among other things
our iPhones
so people will tweet their outrage at
this abuse on the very products of the
abuse
I can't help but notice that President
Biden has not sought to shut down that
supply chain with China
his predecessor did his predecessor
president Trump made it a key plank of
his presidency to decouple from China
China as he pronounced it
but Joe Biden and the rest of the
liberal ruling class have spent decades
sending even more of our manufacturing
to China which means complicity with
that exploitative and flat out forced
labor
she and Putin jail dissidents that's
true
Douglas Mackey is currently facing 11
years in prison American prison for
tweeting out an Anodyne right-wing meme
he was convicted by a federal court a
judge appointed by the Obama Biden
Administration back in March
she and Putin arrest their country's
respective opposition leaders
Joe Biden he wouldn't ever do such a
thing would he
like four times in the same year would
he try to do such a thing I think he
might
Putin seeks to rule over neighboring
countries such as Ukraine Joe Biden to
his credit does not want to invade
Ukraine he just wants to pick their
prosecutors to make sure that the
payments keep coming in to the Biden
family
he wants to make sure that none of those
prosecutors Meddle
and stop the tribute payments
and she's China and Putin's Russia the
ruling parties control the Press
do I even need to say anymore
In fairness though there are still a few
domestic Outlets that will publish
damaging reports about The bidens
but unfortunately no one will get to see
those reports while they matter because
the FBI will go in until the big tech
companies to censor those reports even
in private Communications
the most serious crimes committed by
xi's regime on the uyghurs are
sterilization contraception and abortion
taken together the executive director of
the campaign for uyghurs argues that
these three crimes fit the un's
definition of genocide and I agree
but then
I can't help but notice that President
Biden encourages all those very same
things indiscriminately on our own
people even on children modern liberal
culture tells us that Liberty is the
right to choose
this is how most people today even
conservatives think about Liberty
but this is not the way that our
forebearers thought about Liberty this
is not the way that our civilization has
understood Liberty from the Pagan Greeks
up through the Christian medievals and
Renaissance people all the way up
through just a few hundred years ago
up until that time Liberty was
understood quite differently
even Lord Acton an Ardent liberal a
favorite of Libertarians famously
admitted that Liberty is not the ability
to do what we wish but rather the right
to do what we ought
the 19th century Spanish writer DiNozzo
Cortez put it even more clearly Cortez
wrote quote
when man came from the hands of God he
understood the good and because he
understood he willed it and because he
willed he executed it and by executing
the good his will desired and his
intellect understood he was free
that this is the Christian signification
of Liberty is clear from the following
words of the Gospel you shall know the
truth and the truth shall make you free
we know that Liberty cannot merely be
the absence of external constraint when
we consider the case of the heroin
addict
according to the modern liberal
conception the freest man is the man
with the fewest external constraints
so according to that definition the
freest man in America must be
the heroin addict in San Francisco right
as long as he's got a few bucks in his
pocket however dubiously he acquired
those bucks
as long as he's got a needle that he can
put into his arm well then he can shoot
up to open a filthy Alleyway and no cop
is going to stop him he can loiter he
can defecate in the streets and he can
sleep on the sidewalk until he freezes
and dies of exposure man isn't he free
I don't think so
he is a Slave he's a slave to his
appetites his passions and his lower
will and he knows it by the way
he probably wishes to break his
addiction he almost certainly does
but his appetites Cloud his intellect
and his defective will succumbs to
Temptation until it destroys him
anyone who's ever had a bad habit or a
good habit for that matter
knows that the more you do something the
easier it is to do that thing and the
harder it is to do the opposite
the more you do drugs the easier it is
to do drugs
the more you learn the easier it is to
know things
fact of human nature reveals a second
error with the liberal definition of
Liberty namely
that the better that we become or the
worse that we become the less free we
should be
this is an unfamiliar thought today
what I mean is
so long as we have no habits tastes or
inclinations so long as we are perfectly
neutral then we are perfectly free
according to the Liberals because we are
perfectly disposed to choose between
alternatives
but the moment that we begin to develop
habits and tastes and inclinations which
of course happens to us all the time
whether we want to or not
then suddenly we are less free to choose
between Alternatives the moment we start
shooting heroin the less able we are to
choose not to shoot heroin
the moment we start to learn the less
able we are to fall into error
taken to its logical conclusion we see
the absurdity of the liberal definition
of Liberty in the case of God because
according to the liberal definition God
himself is not free
because God cannot sin
his very being precludes him from evil
and yet does anyone seriously believe
that God the maker of heaven and Earth
of all things visible and invisible is
not free
even an atheist must admit that the very
concept of God demands that God be not
only free but perfectly free and so he
is so how can this be
it's for the same reason that we all
know intuitively that the heroin addict
is not free because freedom is not
impartiality between good and evil right
and wrong truth and falsehood
freedom is not synonymous with choice
on the contrary choice is a defect of
our Liberty which actually consists of
willing and understanding human beings
unique among the animals possess
intellect and will that is what
distinguishes us from the other animals
other animals possess instinct
a Chihuahua can sometimes figure out
where we keep the dog food and just fare
it in there and go eat it out of the
cabinet
but a chihuahua cannot write a poem or
contemplate Justice the best they can do
is sing in Taco Bell commercials and
that is not a very high level of
Consciousness or understanding
as a consequence neither Chihuahuas nor
any other non-human animal is free
we put human beings on trial for
committing crimes because human beings
are expected to know better and act
better
crimes are an abuse of our Liberty
we do not put Chihuahuas on trial
much as sometimes we might like to even
if the little Chihuahua beats a little
it bites a little kid rather at the park
because Chihuahuas cannot abuse their
Liberty because they don't have any
Liberty because they don't have
intellect or will Liberty therefore is
not the maximization of choice but the
Perfection of our understanding and of
our will and since God Alone understands
and wills perfectly God Alone is
perfectly free
and we will be free only in as much as
we align our wills and our intellects
with God
I know that all of this Probably sounds
strange in an age when Reddit tear
atheism Reigns Supreme in politics
but this is how the wisest man of
history have understood the defining
feature of human nature
which brings me back to Joe Biden I know
that was a long digression
through counter-revolutionary political
theologians and but I think it was an
important digression and now we arrive
back at Joe Biden not one of the wisest
men in history
as well as Putin and she
chairman XI peddles contraception
sterilization and abortion on some of
his people through coercion
Biden pushes the same thing on all of
his people but we are told he does so
consensually but
as we have just seen this supposed
consent is rather dubious in part
because children can't consent in part
because the state impels these
procedures and even outright coerces
them in certain cases but also more
broadly because President Biden wields
the power of the state to darken
people's intellect and to compromise
their will
if Liberty consists as it does
in the Perfection of the intellect and
the will then any campaign to undermine
the intellect and the will is an assault
on Liberty she and Putin for all of
their sins don't deny the human reality
of marriage
she and Putin
for all of their sins Don't Force weird
sex stuff on little kids in elementary
schools when the Biden Administration
encourages Vice the free flow of drugs
across our Southern border the
legalization of drugs within the United
States the destruction of the family
promiscuous sex ubiquitous porn abortion
and all of the other vices that Biden
and our liberal Elite exalt as positive
Goods that constitutes an attack on our
will and therefore an attack on our
Liberty
now lest it seem like I am letting
foreign despots off the hook on at least
one issue I think we can give Biden
credit over she or Putin
unlike Putin
Joe Biden has never to my knowledge had
any of his political opponents
assassinated
he leaves that to the clintons
I'm joking I'm joking
that's one point for Biden
but if we're tallying up body counts
while Biden may only imprison political
dissidents rather than assassinate them
he also publicly encourages the killing
of babies in the womb up until the
moment of birth
virtually every Democrat in Congress
just down the road joined him in that
effort when they voted for the so-called
Women's Health protection act which
mercifully failed but which would have
allowed for the killing of babies at all
stages of pregnancy up until the very
moment of birth
this is a far more expansive abortion
policy than exists in either she's China
or Putin's Russia it accounts presently
for over eight hundred thousand corpses
per year and that number would go much
higher if Biden and Congressional
Democrats got their way
Biden unlike our foes overseas actively
undermines the institution of the family
the fundamental political unit
lawlessly opens our national borders and
cloaks his Injustice behind the facade
of democracy
when she and Putin do something rotten
in pursuit of their National interest
they do it as the autocrats that they
are
when Biden does something rotten usually
against our national interest he does so
with the additional Scandal of his doing
so under the dubious guise of our
democracy
which brings me to a crucial point
when I suggest that Joe Biden might be
as evil or more evil a ruler than some
of our foreign adversaries I do not for
one second suggest that America is a
more evil country than Russia or China
I am reluctant to write off any country
in those kinds of Stark terms but even
if I were so inclined
I would continue to believe my own
country to be largely good
to quote The Godfather
I believe in America it's the very first
line
I would also quote it and say you can
act like a man what's the matter with
you but that would be a topic for
another speech
this raises a question though
if America is largely good
and America's rulers are largely bad
and America's government is one of the
people by the people for the people then
one of those statements can't be true